>>Female Presenter: I'm really excited today
to introduce our speaker, Kevin Bleyer.
I was calling him Kevin Blair and he told
me it was Bleyer and it rhymes with "liar."
So, I got it down.
[laughter]
So, one of my favorite parts about hosting
these Tech Talks is obviously getting to come
here and do the intros, 'cause I get to try
my hand at comedy.
I'm a little intimidated today because I'm
introducing Kevin, who's a writer for "The
Daily Show."
So, I'm not gonna try, but I did decide to
use a really quality intro on Kevin that I'd
read and I feel describes his work a little
better than I could.
So, Emmy Award winner Kevin Bleyer is an Emmy
Award winning writer for "The Daily Show"
with Jon Stewart for which he has won multiple
Emmy Awards.
Before re-writing the Constitution, Bleyer
co-authored the number one New York Times
best-seller "Earth: The Book" and negotiated
bipartisan consensus as a writer and producer
for "Politically Incorrect" with Bill Maher
and Dennis Miller.
Since 2008, he's been a term member on the
Counsel of Foreign Relations and since 2009,
has been a contributor to President Obama's
White House correspondence dinner addresses.
So, he secretly runs the government already.
Kevin lives here in New York City where he
regularly poses for portraits.
Please join me in welcoming our guest, Mr.
Kevin Bleyer.
>>Kevin: Wow.
[applause]
That's some highlights.
Wow.
Thank you.
No, please.
Sit down.
You're embarrassing me.
Stop that.
[laughs] I am blushing.
You've done it.
Thank you so much.
It is an honor to be here and heck, sure,
yeah.
It's an honor for you to have me here.
Why not?
I'll agree with you.
That's sweet of you to say.
Truly an honor to be here at Google and I
do feel like this is one of the few places
where I feel it might be more appropriate
for to tell you to turn on your cell phones.
I'm sure you hear that a lot.
My name is Kevin Bleyer.
And to see so many people here and to know
that people are watching online, if it's possible
for someone who just rewrote the entire Constitution
of the United States to say he is humbled,
I guess I could say I'm humbled.
I did in fact, as you have heard, somehow
single-handedly rewrote the entire Constitution
of the United States by myself, without any
help from any of you people.
So, I don't know where you were.
Frankly, I'm exhausted.
Now, when I tell people that I rewrote the
Constitution, the question I often hear either
from their lips or just in my head is, "Well,
why did you do that?"
And there are a dozen very good answers that
are in the book.
There are also a few very poor answers that
are also in the book.
And I'll tell you a few of them right now.
It would be perhaps too convenient, although
not altogether incorrect, to say well, I saw
everyone else rewriting the Constitution,
so why not me?
My turn.
It seemed only fair.
I could also say to you, you know what?
Even if I rewrote the Constitution, knowing
what I know now about the Constitution, I'm
not so sure that anyone would have even noticed.
And I'll tell you what I mean by this.
Most Americans, and I would probably have
to say some of you probably in this room,
too, don't even know exactly what's in the
Constitution.
A few stats I'll throw at you.
More American teenagers can name the Three
Stooges than can name the three branches of
government.
And by the way, that's the Three Stooges.
It's not like it's Justin Bieber.
American teenagers now can name the Three
Stooges more than they can name the three
branches of government.
Nine in ten adults believe that "of the people,
by the people, for the people" is in the Constitution,
even though it is of the Gettysburg Address
by President Abraham Lincoln and for crying
out loud, they probably learned that at some
point.
Most agree this I say to you is that nearly
half of Americans--also true--think that "from
each according to his ability, to each according
to his needs" was written by James Madison,
not Karl Marx.
And by the way, Karl Marx is not one of the
Three Stooges, for those teenagers who happen
to be tuning in.
Nor is he actually a Marx brother.
I mean, he is a Marx brother.
He had brothers, but I don't think they were
known for being very funny.
And so, I tell you when John Boehner himself,
in 2009, stood up his copy of a pocket Constitution
at a rally in Ohio and said "I stand here
with the Founders, with the framers, who wrote
in the Preamble of the Constitution, 'We hold
these truths to be self-evident that all men
are created equal,' and yet didn't realize
that's actually the second sentence in the
Declaration of Independence, I thought, "You
know what?
There's an opportunity here.
Perhaps I can step up."
Now in fairness, and I've been careful to
point this out anywhere I've been, I begrudge
no one.
I denigrate him not at all, nor do I denigrate
anyone with these blind spots because I'm
sure my blind spots are just as large.
They certainly were before I started this
project.
Had you asked me a few years ago, before I
started researching this book, how does the
Constitution begin?
I may have said, "It was the best of times,
it was the worst of times."
[laughter]
Which, by the way, is not altogether untrue
if you think about what happened in 1787.
But an even better answer to the question
of why I rewrote the Constitution is this.
I had no choice, no less than Thomas Jefferson
himself told me I had to.
Thomas Jefferson, who I think we can all agree,
is one of the more foundry of the Founding
Fathers and therefore someone we should probably
listen to, said to the world back then that
every Constitution on Earth naturally expires
at the end of 19 years.
If it be enforced longer, it is an act of
force and not of right.
Every Constitution.
So, in other words, by his math, our Constitution
has been expired for over two centuries, dead,
kaput, an ex-parrot you might say.
His words.
And so, in his math, I should have written
this over 200 years ago.
It should have been rewritten eleven times
by now.
And frankly, I feel bad I'm just getting to
it now.
I've been slacking for two centuries.
So, I owe all of you an apology.
What's more, in my research, I also, even
though we see people cozy up to the Constitution,
say they know what's in it, cite it, put it
on posters, often incorrectly.
Even though it seems to be a weapon in the
debate, so to speak, and used as a weapon
unfortunately in the debate, I still feel
like it needs some good publicity these days.
And I have some very significant statistics
also that suggest that.
Twenty-five years ago, of the 170 countries
that then existed, a full 160 of them--and
keep in mind, some of these countries are
rather old.
Of those countries, 160 actually based their
Constitutions, at least in part, on our Constitution.
In the last 25 years, when fledgling democracies
go shopping around for a constitution, what
percentage of them now do so?
Precisely zero, according to a study in the
Harvard Law Review, which I found quite rather
amusing or interesting or rather devastating,
too.
Not to mention that just a couple months ago,
no less than, justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
herself was in Egypt, and she told the Egyptians
if she were designing a democracy in 2012,
she would actually not use the American Constitution
as a model.
Now that was surprising to me because you
think of her as someone who is out to protect
every clause of the Constitution.
And if she's not going to blindingly, unthinkingly,
and ignorantly as I am doing, go out and cheer
lead for the Constitution, at least I can--even
though I'm totally unauthorized to do so--the
only time I wear a robe is at the spa.
Now, I will tell you that what these other
countries are doing is they're looking to
other country's Constitutions.
More often now, they're looking to South Africa,
a fairly new Constitution, and to, and this
is especially galling to me, an American patriot,
they're looking to Canada.
[laughs] Apparently because those Constitutions,
in their estimation, care more about human
rights and something called the environment.
Environment.
Oh, environment.
That's what it is.
And finally, I suppose the most legitimate
reason that I rewrote the Constitution is
I figure, well, if Apple can rewrite their
iTunes service agreement every 19 minutes,
certainly I can rewrite the Constitution every
19 years.
It seems fair.
And by the way, that brings up, I wanna give
due diligence and due credence to the people
here today and say that I owe you a thank
you as well because after suggesting all these
statistics, I want to read how Google actually
became a part of my research, or as I call
it, my me-search.
Yes.
That's right.
I did win an Emmy for word play like that.
Ridiculous.
So, I'll read this section.
It's early on.
Oh, yeah.
I'll read this section first.
[reads from book]
"Is it any wonder, I ask you, that President
George W Bush once called the Constitution,
and I quote, "a goddamned piece of paper?"
Not to me.
Because unlike you, I googled that quote just
now.
Apparently it is apocryphal, which I also
googled and learned it is another way of saying
'not true.'
Never happened.
Bogus.
Evidently, a few years ago, a left-wing muckraker
spread the rumor that one of the President's
aides advised him not to renew the Patriot
Act--on account of it being unconstitutional--and
the President supposedly said, quote 'Stop
throwing the Constitution in my face.
It's just a goddamned piece of paper.'
Oh sure, there might be some truthiness to
that, but it is, nonetheless, a lie.
Didn't happen.
The 43rd President of the United States never
said that the Constitution he swore an oath
to uphold quote 'to the best of his ability
through rain or sleet or gloom of night.'
--note to self, Google 'presidential oath
of office-- was quote 'just a goddamned piece
of paper.'
After all, it couldn't possibly be a goddamned
piece of paper, not when our third President
had already and long ago declared it quote
'a mere thing of wax.'
Thomas Jefferson, not long after the Constitution
was enforced, lamented aloud that the Justices
of the Supreme Court had already usurped the
right of quote 'exclusively explaining the
Constitution' and therefore could, as the
nation's first judicial activists, 'twist
and shape it' unquote into any form they please,
like so much revolutionary Play-Doh.
By calling dibs on the first constitutional
metaphor, Jefferson has beaten Bush to the
punch by two hundred years.
It is no goddamned piece of paper, it is a
mere thing of wax.
Now, to suggest that violating the Constitution,
as Thomas Jefferson admitted that he did in
the Louisiana Purchase, is somehow uncommon,
or unpresidential, or worse, un-American,
overlooks an inconvenient truth.
Namely, yes, if not for that flagrant violation
of the Constitution, known as the Louisiana
Purchase, by none other then Thomas Jefferson
we'd hardly recognize the country we see on
so many elementary school maps.
America wouldn't be America.
If the third President of the United States
hadn't shrugged off the document he had sworn
to protect quote 'by hook or by crook' unquote--note
to self,seriously man, Google the presidential
oath of office already--and doubled the size
of the nation with the stroke of a pen, even
though the Constitution gave him no such authority,
the Western Coast of America would be on the
Eastern bank of the Mississippi.
We would be crowning thy good with brotherhood
from sea to shining St. Louis.
Jefferson knew this, too.
In embarking on the most aggressive executive
action in history, he was quite aware he was
sticking his neck out too far.
The Constitution might not approve.
'The Executive,' he wrote, referring to himself,
'in seizing the fugitive occurrence which
so much advances the good of the country have
done an act beyond the Constitution.'
Jefferson rationalized his decision, telling
himself that his act of subversion was a vote
of confidence in the fledgeling nation.
Quote 'I did this for your own good,' he wrote
plainly.
His guilty conscience even spurred him to
devise an excuse if the pitchfork-wielding
guardians of the Constitution came knocking
at his door.
Quote 'I thought of my duty to risk myself
for you.'
Unquote.
It is a startling admission for any President
of the United States.
His sworn assignment was--thank you Google--to
quote 'preserve, protect, and defend the Constitution.'
His higher duty was to thwart it."
But now the question absolutely will remain,
why rewrite the Constitution?
Why do a comic, fraudulent, jeremiad take
down of every article, Amendment and the Preamble,
rather than just point at it and say, "Hey,
it's not so bad."
I actually begin the very beginning of the
book with an anecdote that explains specifically
why I decided to do this.
And it goes a little bit like, by the way,
this is my bookmark.
It's an occupational hazard.
In fact, it's the exact same bookmark that
you see there.
I posed with it.
So, here's the anecdote that explains every
word in this book.
[reads from book]
"Their beloved bell was in jeopardy.
It had hung dutifully for decades, pealing
hourly from its steeple above the Pennsylvania
State House, breaking the peace of the Philadelphia
streets, only to remind its citizens that
time had marched on and all was well.
But these were no longer peaceful times.
It was 1777, a year after America had declared
her independence from the British crown and
only days after her lion-hearted general,
George Washington, had suffered a withering
defeat at the Battle of Brandywine.
All signs were that Philadelphia, the revolutionary
capitol, might well be the next to fall.
Fearing that the king's men would melt any
metal they found into British cannons, a few
American patriots confiscated their own bell,
soon to be known appropriately as the 'Liberty
Bell,' and hid it in the safest place they
could find--under a pile of horse manure.
The gambit worked.
The marauding redcoats never got their British
hands on our American Liberty.
The lesson learned back then rings as clear
today.
Sometimes, in order to save and honor something
we cherish, we have to shit on it."
[laughter]
You're mad at me over there.
I can tell.
So, yes.
That, I would think, justifies.
It gives me the political cover to write this
book.
I was also amused, as you might have seen
just a few weeks ago, the maintenance crew
at Independence Hall in Philadelphia where
the Liberty Bell is.
I had spent an entire day and a half adding
a protective shellac to the outside of the
Liberty Bell.
And I can't help but think, knowing as we
do now, where the Liberty Bell has been.
They're about 240 years too late.
The Founders actually knew this.
And most of them suspected at the end of that
time in Philadelphia that the Constitution
that they wrote by September is, as the kids
might say, a bit of a hot mess.
For starters, this venerated document doesn't
mention the word "slavery" or the word "democracy"
or even "Facebook."
It plays favorites among the states, giving
Wyoming as many Senators as New York.
And I mean, come on.
It has typos and misspellings and a smudge
that, and this is true, may or may not be
a comma empowering the government to seize
your house depending on which Constitutional
scholar you ask.
It is, as we know, scrawled with the quill
of a goose on the skin of a goat.
And its Preamble, its famous Preamble, its
most famous introductory passage was written
by delegate Gouverneur Morris, a man with
a peg-leg.
They called him the Peg Leg Morris.
And while his Preamble is notoriously beautiful,
it nonetheless, gives our sacred Constitution
hardly a leg to stand on.
People.
OK.
There we go.
Groan if you must and you should.
But the Founders knew this, too.
And in fact, by the way, just so you know,
New York is number one.
I should say this.
I spent some time in Article 4, which the
Article 4 is actually supposed to referee
disputes among the states.
And sometimes it doesn't do such a great job.
So, I decided the only way to really solve
the problem is to go ahead and rank the states
already.
Now, I ranked New York as number one, obviously.
But depending how the rest of this afternoon
goes, I'm just saying, we could fall a few
spots.
George Washington himself, George Washington
himself, the man who presided over the Constitutional
Convention, agrees with me about the flaws
in the Constitution.
It was he who predicted that the flawed Constitution
would become controversial.
"A child of fortune," he said.
"To be fostered by some but buffeted by others."
And when the Constitutional Convention was
over, he said explicitly, quote "I wished
it had been made more perfect."
Benjamin Franklin himself stomached it only
quote "with all its faults."
And in fact, on the very last day of the Constitutional
Convention, George Washington, excuse me,
Benjamin Franklin gave a speech that I think
somewhat hilariously sums up what he really
probably thought about their handiwork that
day.
It was in the same speech where he said that
he wished everyone would doubt their infallibility
and put their name to the measure.
And he finished the speech by saying this,
and I think--.
You just need to read in-between the lines
a little bit, see what he's really saying
to understand what he actually felt about
the four months of compromise that they had
just done.
He says, quote "I confess that there are several
parts of this Constitution which I do not
at present approve.
But I am not sure I shall never approve them.
I doubt whether any other convention we can
obtain may be able to make a better Constitution.
Thus, I consent to this Constitution because
I expect no better.
And because I am not sure that it is not the
best," which you might say he sounds like
a Republican endorsing Mitt Romney.
[laughter]
Exactly.
Damning with faint praise.
Whereas, unlike my book, which I hope people
understand the true intent as Justice Scalia
did.
And I'll talk about him a little bit later.
That I'm hopefully praising with faint damnation.
You'll see that I actually come back around.
I don't want to spoil the ending.
I don't want to tell you that the butler did
or didn't do it.
But if anything, only the accomplice.
And I'll get to that a little bit, too.
Because as these Founders knew, while we think
of the Constitution as yes, the painstakingly
designed blueprint drawn up by what Thomas
Jefferson called "an assembly of demigods,"
who laid the foundation for the sturdiest
republic ever created.
All true.
By the end of that summer in Philadelphia,
the framers knew the truth that the Constitution
was not exactly a blueprint.
They would have agreed that it was a bit of,
and I use this phrase as I wrote it a year
ago, a bit of an Etch-A-Sketch.
A haphazard series of blunders.
They admitted that they had to shake clean
and redraw dozens of times during a sweltering
summer of petty debates, drunken ramblings,
wild improvisation, and desperate compromise.
You have to imagine it.
They were, I mean, we had this last weekend
in New York, right?
It was miserably hot.
And Philadelphia was even hotter.
And they were there for four months in the
sweltering summer of Philadelphia wearing
powdered wigs, wool coats.
They locked the doors.
They shuttered the windows for privacy.
There was no such thing as air-conditioning.
It was an unventilated room.
There was a prison riot right across the street.
Butchers were throwing animal carcasses that
they were done with, truly, within feet of
the Pennsylvania State House.
So, you can imagine.
it was pungent all over the place.
Not to mention that they were, in fact, drinking
beer for breakfast.
Now, the truth of the matter is, most people
drank beer for breakfast because it was cleaner
than water.
But nonetheless, the fact remains, they were
drinking beer for breakfast.
And in fact, you don't actually have to--.
I do a pretty lengthy explanation of what
actually transpired during those four months.
And I conclude, and I explain how it all concluded
as well, if I can find the page because my
bookmark has disappeared.
It's now over here somewhere.
Ah, there we go.
[pause]
Hmm.
There we go.
So again, after four months.
Now we understand how it all happened.
Or rather, almost didn't.
The Constitution wasn't only a miracle at
Philadelphia, written by an assembly of demigods.
It was that, but it was also the contrary.
What began as a measured, deliberate effort
to rescue a beleaguered country became a perpetual
unresolved motion machine--a maddening cycle
of non-binding votes by a parade of toothless
committees, marked by fits and starts, fights
and full-stops, conducted by a combative group
of exhausted, drunken, broke, petty, partisan,
scheming, squabbling, bloviating, back-stabbing,
grandstanding, god-forsaken, posturing, restless,
cow-tipping, homesick, cloistered, claustrophobic,
sensory-deprived, under-oxygenated, fed up,
talked out, overheated delegates so distraught
and despairing they threatened violence, secession,
foreign allegiance and even prayer.
As Benjamin Franklin said, "and concluded
for those who didn't abandon the proceedings
altogether, with as much pre-meditation and
forethought as a game of musical chairs.
The last, least abhorrent, mutually somewhat
acceptable idea on the table when the music
stopped, or the heat became too unbearable,
or the liqueur too strong, or the rioting
too loud, or the pressure too intense, or
the company too loathsome, or the wigs too
uncomfortable, or the patience too thin, became
the law of the land" as much the product of
yes, an assembly of demigods as yes, some
might say a confederacy of what could be dunces
on occasion.
From page one, the Constitution is, by its
own admission, a great compromise.
It is also what you get when you drink beer
for breakfast.
Now, amusingly, they didn't just drink beer
I'm actually understating that because the
truth of the matter is they drank a lot of
beer at that time.
They drank a lot of everything at that time.
The statistics are astounding, but I'll just
point this out.
When they finally decided what was gonna be
in the Constitution, and they knew they were
about to sign it, well, they threw a party,
'cause they knew that they'd finally be able
to bid adieu to each other.
But this is what happened that night.
They were about to add their signatures to
an extremely anticipated official document
that many of them had extremely mixed feelings
about.
So the delegates did what anyone might do
under such pressure.
They drank themselves silly.
After they toasted the occasion, they drowned
their miseries.
They had spent four months compromising some
of their values, perhaps they could drink
their guilt away.
They certainly tried.
In the span of just a few hours, the 55 men
who crowded City Tavern on Friday, September
14th, 1787, guzzled enough alcohol to fell
an Army Regiment.
Sixty bottles of claret.
Fifty-four bottles of Madeira.
Fifty bottles of old stock.
Vats of porter, cider, and beer, and what
has been described as "some" bowls of rum.
They weren't just pledging their sacred honor.
They were pledging a frat.
So wild did the celebration get, the City
Tavern, a place quite familiar with drunkenness,
took the unusual step of sending along a bill
for quote unquote "breakage."
Pretty amusing to me.
Honestly, the miracle at Philadelphia is that
the Constitution wasn't written on the back
of a bar napkin.
That's a big question.
Which actually brings me to my drinking companion,
as I had just mentioned.
What are the more fortunate accidents really
in getting to research and write this book
was getting to have lunch with Justice Scalia.
Now, of course, as you can understand, I wanted
to meet with Justice Scalia because I thought
who on the face of the planet, let alone in
the country, would really be most amenable
to a page one rewrite of the Constitution?
And you gotta assume it's the man who's devoted
his entire life to protecting every phrase,
clause, and punctuation in it.
I was a little bit alarmed, or surprised,
I guess I should say, that he agreed to meet
with me.
But of course, also thrilled that he would.
I should also say, of course, the truth of
the matter is that he actually agrees with
Thomas Jefferson.
Thomas Jefferson, who said the Constitution
be rewritten every 19 years.
He doesn't agree with that part, but he agrees
with Jefferson that the Constitution is, and
this is his words, "dead."
The difference is, between him and Thomas
Jefferson, is that Justice Scalia means dead
as a compliment, apparently.
He means quit trying to revive it.
He means honor it for what we know it was
and adore it for all of those merits.
So, he agreed to meet.
And we did, in fact, talk of a lot of things
in the Constitution.
But I knew at some point that I would have
to turn our attentions to his bread and butter--the
Third Article, the judicial branch, where
of course he makes his living.
And I had to, what I hope I do in this book
is address the actual issues that people have
with the Articles and Amendments.
My solutions are rather absurd.
But I do address the actual issues.
And one of the issues that people have with
the Third Amendment, excuse me, the Third
Article, the Supreme Court, is this idea.
And when I mention these words, you could
see what happened.
I broached the subject and I said, "Well,
Justice, Your Honor, you know that some people
have a problem with lifetime ten--."
And as soon as I got to ten--, he picked up
a fork, poked it at me and with a devilish
grin said, "Don't you dare.
Don't you dare change lifetime tenure.
And if you do, at least grandfather me in
because I like my job."
Fair enough.
But now here's the thing.
The Constitution itself says nothing about
Supreme Court Justices having lifetime tenure.
It merely says the Justices shall hold their
offices quote unquote "during good behavior."
Now, for a bunch of very good reasons, early
on, we decided to interpret that as lifetime
tenure because kings were removing judges
willy nilly from the bench.
So, they thought, "Let's go the other way
with this."
But nonetheless, it doesn't actually say lifetime
tenure.
It says merely during good behavior.
And I felt it, my job, to say to him, "Well,
let's consider in 2012 whether or not we should
really still have lifetime tenure."
And he put down the fork and agreed to listen
to me.
And this is what transpired when that happened.
[clears throat]
[reads from book]
"I don't bother lecturing Justice Scalia on
any of this.
After decades of legal study and 25 years
of service as one of America's top Judges,
he's been fully briefed.
Instead, I begin my cross-examination.
'How about you?'
I ask.
'How about me what?' he counters.
'Can you imagine just walking away?'
I ask.
'Of course I can,' he scoffs, with a couldn't
care less tone that implies he'd just as soon
leave today if only he hadn't signed a two-year
lease on his Supreme Court locker.
'When?'
I ask.
Like I've said before, he says, 'As soon as
I'm not firing on all eight cylinders, when
I'm not doing the job as well as I used to,
it'll be time to go.
'How will you know when that is?'
He looks me straight in the eye.
'I'll know.'
'So, you don't need some outside authority
limiting the term of your servi--?'
'I'm fairly aware of the requirements of the
position,' he interrupts me.
'I'll know when I can no longer fulfill them.'
And yet, 'what if I told you, Your Honor,
that someone even more powerful than you says
your wrong about that?'
He looks at me.
'And who is that?'
'Someone you know quite well.'
He looks at me again, wondering if he should
ask.
'Who?'
If this were a case in some courtroom drama,
this is the moment when I would stand slowly,
scan the jury, look back at the judge and
call on my surprise witness.
May it please the Courts, I now call to the
stand, dramatic pause, the current Chief Justice
of the Supreme Court of the United States.
If this were indeed a courtroom drama, the
double doors in the back of the courtroom
would fly open.
The stenographer would record the reaction
of the gallery.
Audible gasps.
And Chief Justice John G Roberts, Jr. would
saunter up the aisle, hesitating only long
enough to lock eyes with fellow Justice Scalia
and feel his glare.
Et tu, Roberte?
Roberts would then explain to the ladies and
gentlemen of the jury that no matter what
he says or how he pleads for mercy, Justice
Antonin Scalia should have been kicked off
the court exactly ten years ago.
Back in real life, I explain what the hell
I'm talking about.
When he was a lawyer in the Reagan White House,
22 years before, he joined the Supremes.
John Roberts argued on behalf of the 15-year
term limits for Supreme Court Justices.
It was both a pragmatic proposal, as he saw
it.
The Founders quote 'adopted life tenure at
a time when people simply did not live as
long as they do now' unquote.
And a principled one for many of the reasons
I've tried out here at lunch.
A judge insulated from the normal occurrence
of life for 25 or 30 years was a rarity then,
but is becoming commonplace today, he wrote
in a White House memo.
Setting a term of, say, 15 years would ensure
that Federal Judges would not lose all touch
with quote reality through decades of Ivory
Tower existence unquote.
It is an indictment of lifetime tenure, too
compelling to ignore.
As I finished explaining, one thing becomes
clear.
Scalia knew nothing of this.
'Is that so?' he asks.
'Has Roberts thought that?'
I have out-lawyered the longest serving Associate
Justice of the Supreme Court.
'Really?
He thought that?' he asks again.
'Yes,' I say, pausing a beat for dramatic
effect, 'yes he did.'
For a moment, Scalia seemed speechless.
He can muster no defense, even though we're
sitting in the National Gallery, not the Supreme
Court, and eating lunch, not arguing case
law, I am tempted to shout, 'The prosecution
rests,' slam an imaginary briefcase and march
out triumphantly.
But I don't.
I stay.
And Scalia's grin returns.
'Well,' he says, 'I doubt he does any more.'
[laughs] He has a good point.
Roberts doesn't think that anymore.
When Roberts himself was asked about his previous
comments at his confirmation hearings in 2005,
he flip-flopped.
Predictably, his perspective on the issue
had evolved.
As the law professor Larry Sabato has eloquently
put it, 'On the issue of lifetime tenure,
where one stands depends on where one sits.'
Scalia's joke, nonetheless, seems to put him
back on offense.
'So,' he asks.
'So, it was an argument that had stymied me
before.'
'So what?'
'So?
Are you going to make me retire with your
new Constitution?
I mean, I've been here longer than 15 years.'
Oh, he's not on the attack.
He's throwing himself on the mercy of my courts.
'No, sir.
No, sir.'
I'm not here to fire Justice Scalia, though
I appreciate his acknowledgment of my authority
to do so.
'So, what exactly do you propose?'
I thought he'd never ask.
'Simple,' I say.
'Your new Article Three.
The judicial power of the United States shalt
be vested in one Supreme Court and the Judges
shall hold their offices during good behavior.'
Scalia seems confused.
'But that's what Article Three already says.'
'Not exactly,' I clarify.
'I drop the u from behavior to make it more
American.'
[laughter]
'But otherwise, that's Article Three of the
Constitution.'
'Indeed it is, Your Honor.
Indeed it is.'
It was, I was certain, a remedy for Article
Three, that an originalist like Justice Scalia
could not help but support.
We take it literally.
We revive the original Article and we'll honor
it's original language.
Judges shall hold their offices during good
behavior.
I had him dead to rights.
Surely he, a man who swore by the letter of
the law would swear by the letter of this
law, that is, save one letter, to which he
owed his entire career.
I was proud of my judicial jujitsu."
Thank you.
One person, right?
Too much.
"'But who,' he asks, 'determines good behavior?'
'Good behavior,' I correct him.
[laughter]
Thank you.
He was pronouncing the "u," you're right.
" 'That's what I said,' he says.
'Who gets to decide?'
Well, I've anticipated this question.
Scalia listens closely as I propose a judging
body composed of three people appointed by
the President, whose sole responsibility is
to determine whether the Justices are passing
the good behavior test, as revived by my new
Constitution.
He gets what I'm aiming at.
'A Supreme Supreme Court,' he says with a
laugh.
Scalia is evidently amused by the idea.
I can tell he's not ruling it out.
'Just one question,' he says.
I raise my chin and allow it.
'Yes, Your Honor?'
'How long do they serve?'
I hadn't thought of that."
You can probably tell from this, I mean, first
of all, he trumped me at every turn, even
when I tried to be funny, he was funnier.
When I tried to out-lawyer him, of course
I knew I was in over my head.
But when I say that Justice Scalia is funny,
it's not just me saying that.
I can say to you right now, Justice Scalia
is officially funny.
And in fact, he is officially the funniest
Supreme Court Justice on the bench.
Now, how do we know this?
We know this because a few years ago, the
New York Times actually reported on this.
I guess this was about six or seven years
ago.
There was a St. Louis Law Review study that
someone had thought to finally, well, they
just released a big batch of Supreme Court
transcripts.
And someone thought to count the number of
times laughter had been annotated by the stenographer
after a Supreme Court Justice spoke.
And by far, Scalia got the most laughs in
the chamber.
In fact, he's twice as funny as Steven Breyer
you'll be happy to know.
Nineteen times funnier than Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsburg.
[laughter]
Now, we don't know about Clarence Thomas because
Clarence Thomas, as you may or may not know,
has actually not spoken in the chamber for
seven years, something like that.
So, it's possible and I think you at Google
can appreciate this, it's possible that mathematically
speaking, he is infinitely funny.
[laughter]
It's possible that every time he opens his
mouth, it's a killer laugh.
He could be in fact the Patch Adams of the
Supreme Court.
We don't know.
Now, people say, "OK, Kevin.
But what do you really think about the Constitution?
Are you actually suggesting through your comic
jeremiad here that the Constitution should
be scrapped and sold for parts and start it
over from scratch?"
And that's a fair question.
And as I said before, the butler, I don't
wanna spoil it too much, but I will say the
butler didn't do it entirely.
Perhaps, it was an accomplice.
And I'll read to you the final section of
the book.
It's not, I'm not spoiling it for you.
So, you can still pick up a copy later and
enjoy the interior part.
But this is essentially how I wrap up that
I think you'll enjoy.
Keeping in mind the story about the Liberty
Bell.
So, this is a bit of a book end.
[reads from book]
"Their beloved stamp was in jeopardy.
It had been designed carefully and artfully,
graced not only with a stately visage of an
adored and enduring national icon, but also
with the denomination chosen to reflect just
how long it would last.
Nay, how long it should last.
Forever.
A forever stamp.
It was 2011, 125 years after the statue it
featured had been dedicated as a gift from
France as a memorial to independence.
Liberty enlightening the world.
And to honor her long journey across seas
and centuries, three billion stamps had been
printed by the Patriots at the United States
Postal Service.
Two billion had already been issued.
Countless licked or peeled and stuck and sent
far across town, across the country, and around
the globe to enlighten the world one envelope
at a time.
Alas, forever wouldn't last forever.
One eagle-eyed philatelist, armed only with
a jeweler's loupe, a rabid obsession with
detail, and way too much time on his hands
made a shocking discovery.
The lady on the stamp wasn't the 305 foot
copper and iron neoclassical figure standing
sentry on an island in New York Harbor.
No, sir.
The lady on the stamp was the pint-sized knock-off
on the Las Vegas strip, overlooking not New
York, New York, but the New York, New York
casino.
She hadn't welcomed the huddled masses yearning
to breathe free in the New World.
She welcomed obsessive gamblers yearning to
sidle up to the three 99 All-You-Can-Eat Buffet.
Less the stuff of immigrants' hopes and dreams--a
real-life Lady Liberty--more the stuff of
fiberglass and Styrofoam, a replica Lady Luck.
In other words, are you telling me we've got
three billion of these?
Now, a small discolored rectangle that mars
her crown's most prominent center spike--after
all, the real Lady Liberty wouldn't be caught
dead with such a blemish--was the tall-tale
giveaway.
Someone, somewhere had merely raided a stock
photography service and thought, 'Yeah, that
seems about right.
It must be her.
And if it's not, I doubt anyone will notice.'
Someone noticed.
Once alerted to its gaffe, the United States
Postal Service released an official statement,
but not of apology, of adoration.
Quote 'We still love the stamp design and
would've selected the photograph anyway.'
They admitted no defeat, made no excuses,
announced no recall.
They also--it must be said--made me proud
to be an American, where at least I know I'm
free to pretend I totally meant to do that.
Even when I totally screwed up.
After all, what was the Postal Service to
do?
Should it deny it made a mistake as original
author James Madison might have wished in
that summer of 1787?
And yes, as Antonin Scalia might still advise
today.
Should it recall the stamp and continue living
in the past?
That was the unfortunate choice Jonathan Dayton
made in his later years when he, the youngest
delegate at the Constitutional Convention,
stayed so fixated on his participation in
Philadelphia that he never once updated even
his manner of dress.
The Last of the Cocked Hats, they called him.
A walking example of arrested development.
Or should it make a bold, wholesale makeover
in a staggering miraculous flurry of glorious
inspiration as I, Kevin Bleyer, your hero
and humble servant have done in these pages?
Well, even if it should, it didn't.
Instead of promising a more perfect stamp,
the Postal Service insisted the stamp was
a more perfect stamp, one that, despite injuries
and usurpations brought on by a sloppy postal
researcher, still secures the blessings of
the Liberty as we know her--life-size and
in full.
It interpreted the advice of Thomas Jefferson--that
we not look at stamps, or anything really,
with sanctimonious reverence and deem them
like the ark of the covenant.
And of James Madison, too, that we not suffer
a blind veneration for antiquity, as something
slightly different--that we should just get
over ourselves, stick with the program, and
meet at the craps table.
Baby needs a new pair of shoes.
The lesson shines forth as bright and unmistakable
as the flame in Lady Liberty's outstretched
hand.
Sometimes, in order to honor an icon that
defines us as a nation, whether it be a giant
green woman holding a torch, or a Constitution
of the United States of America, we should
just roll with what we've got because it's
still pretty damn awesome."
So, I would say, now that I've justified this
book's existence, my new Constitution's existence,
to Justice Scalia, of course to you here at
Google and around the world, I'll just conclude
with this thought before I answer a couple
of your, what I hope will be, softball questions.
And you're probably asking yourself, "Kevin,
alright.
But does the world really need yet another
book about a guy who single-handedly rewrote
the Constitution by himself?"
And I would say yes.
Yes, it does because, ladies and gentlemen,
the Constitution, I don't need to tell you,
is hot.
Like Hunger Games hot.
Like 50 Shades of Gray hot.
In fact, Jon Stewart called my book "Fifty
Shades of Red, White, and Blue."
I'm very thankful.
Here's why.
People are quoting it, even though they haven't
read it.
People are hiding behind it, even though they're
not quite sure what it says.
And as a piece of literature, the only thing
that would make the Constitution hotter I
tell you, was if James Madison were a vampire.
It is so popular that right now, somewhere
in America, yes, a thousand Tea Partiers are
misquoting it.
It's so amazing that somewhere yes, Kanye
West is interrupting an acceptance speech
to insist that it should've won.
It's so exciting that somewhere, oh boy, Anthony
Weiner is tweeting pics of himself having
just read it.
Which is why, on behalf of America, I have
paid every price for every burden and yes,
saved every receipt in my quest to assure
survival.
"And why now?"
you ask.
Well, at a time when Michelle Bachmann believes
that the Battles of Lexington and Concord
were fought in New Hampshire, at a time when
Sarah Palin believes Paul Revere made his
midnight ride to warn the British that we
were armed, and a time when yes, John Boehner
believes that we hold these truths to be self-evident
is his favorite part of the Constitution,
even though it's the Declaration of Independence,
it shouldn't be too hard to believe this,
that I, Kevin Bleyer, having no qualifications,
am the most qualified man to rewrite the Constitution
of the United States.
I do hope, if you get it, you enjoy it.
And if you do, I hope you help me ratify it.
Thank you very much.
I'm happy to take a few questions if we have
anything, I think we have five or ten minutes
before we have to wrap up.
So, thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
[applause]
Thank you.
I guess there's a couple microphones even
in the aisle.
Ah, here's.
No?
No.
OK.
[laughs] Caught ya.
Caught you, too.
Saw that.
Alright.
Well, anyway, thank you very much.
It's been much appreciated.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
>>Male #1: What, I'm curious, I will get the
book.
>>Kevin: Yeah, yeah.
>>Male #1: But I was curious about your treatment
of the four limited times to secure their
works and--.
>>Kevin: I couldn't hear you.
Sorry.
>>Male #1: Copyright and clause.
>>Kevin: I do address a little bit under the
free, in the First Amendment, a little bit.
But I don't get into the nitty gritty the
way I'm sure the people at Google in here
would appreciate.
But here's one, two thoughts I would say to
you.
First of all, to be exhaustive to rewrite
every Preamble, every Article, and every Amendment,
I have to do a little bit of cherry-picking.
But what I love is going through, be on this
book tour, especially getting people's suggestions
as to what should be in the paperback version.
So, I actually could address that as well.
And not to mention more broadly, I love this
because I don't pretend to know all the answers.
I only pretend to know all the answers.
So, I'm sure people at Google will probably
have some good suggestions for me as far as
how I should address copyright issues in the
next version, which I shall write in at least
19 years as Thomas Jefferson told me to.
Yes, please.
>>Male #2: So, the one question I have, I
have a bunch, but I think the things I'm most
curious about are, what did you find most
surprising about reading the document?
What do you feel like is something that a
lot of Americans in general would be surprised
to know is in the Constitution?
>>Kevin: Just how, for lack of a better word,
dysfunctional, I guess is the regular word
the Constitutional Convention itself was.
I mean, it was a maddening cycle of compromise,
like I told you.
We know of it as the Great Compromise, but
we don't know that they did not make any decisions
on what was going to be in the Constitution
until the very last minute.
And that was merely because they were so sick
of each other.
They kept trying and trying over again and
they didn't address the Executive Branch until
the middle of the summer.
And even when they did, the famous phrase
is when they brought it up, a considerable
pause ensued.
In other words, no one had any idea how to
design the Presidency.
They literally started writing the Constitution
before they decided what was going to be in
it.
They got so sick of each other that they established
an even smaller committee, "style and arrangement"
they called it.
That was a group of, I forget, five or ten
people.
But they would at night essentially say, "Well,
here's this.
Let's give this a shot."
And then the next morning, they said, "How
does this look?
Does it look good?"
And they would actually vote on that.
it's ultimately what they did.
So, it's surprising to me that while we know,
of course, they were debating, we didn't know
that people like Luther Martin were getting
so drunk in the morning that he would give
a six-hour speech and derail the Constitutional
Convention for two days.
It's pretty astounding.
That actual part of history was the most surprising
to me.
I really enjoyed learning about it.
And I think the joy in learning about it hopefully
is manifest on pages.
>>Male #2: Thank you.
>>Kevin: Thank you.
Alright.
Well, again, I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much for coming out and sharing
your lunch hour with me.
[applause]
Thanks a lot.
Thank you very much.